oh you too now you know me I am an Asian
American specifically in Korean America
now that you guys already don't know I
am from cultural California where yes
issues of racism and Prejudice are very
evident but not as much as other places
in the United States in my personal
opinion or you just be the fact that
people are just better at hiding it over
here than other places but every now and
then I will run into a handful of
socially in net human beings to be sure
I know I'm a teacher how not to sound
like a [ __ ] idiot every time you meet
an Asian person so you already know what
it is LGI baby let's get it let's go
number one the word oriental is not the
PC version of saying agent
look at that with dresses because
despite popular belief it is not the
equivalent I'm saying african-american
but black you sound like a [ __ ] idiot
oh yeah but why does that let you want
to punish in looking to trade spices
unless if you are going to use the word
oriental do not use the pronoun you in
front of it well you are eventual sparf
and test you Orientals but are we so
rare Tamagotchi what up and I'm willing
to give people the benefit of the doubt
and chalk it up to ignorance because at
least they're trying but by now I have
traveled all over the United States and
I have come to the conclusion that there
are a handful of people out there that
still believe that Pokemon is an ongoing
documentary of life in Asia my god this
fellow came on commit a little fellow he
caught me number two when you meet an
Asian person
stop telling us everything you know
about Asia listen that's not gonna help
you get your agent Carter that's not the
way to do it I don't think you wanna
stop doing that [ __ ] in front of my
parents that should make me look bad
yeah how come my wife Jabbar know more
about a Claudia than you are ready see
it's like that show you one [ __ ]
Korean drama you gonna embarrass back
you want to know the best way
you to get it done you gotta eat our
food and no I'm not talking about chow
mein and potstickers [ __ ] I'll
talk about you mother eat [ __ ] that even
most Asian people won't eat cuz you
already know what it cuz there's you
people it is supposed to be garbage
we call it delicacy quite no have some
campbellton Cala pick that's my favorite
here's our Asian card number three if
you want to know a specific ethnicity
just don't guess because that is going
to get [ __ ] you don't see Asian people
doing that [ __ ] to each other out now
the hell would you do it you know why we
don't give it because even we know the
time then a lot of us look a lot like
what Asian people talk to white people
we don't care we just leave that white
it tough you about the human being you
know what some dumbass once said to me
well it's just an easy conversation
topic
what else do I ask about [ __ ] maybe my
name you know what time I introduce
myself to a gentleman and you know what
the first thing he said to me was the
Vietnam War was crazy huh you know what
at that point but even I was like
[ __ ] no man what the hell do you
think they're talking about somebody's
homeland is gonna make them love you
more hmm I feel like sometimes a lot of
people want some kind of cultural
affirmation from us let me tell you
something you like the boy he come my
school your Excellencies are so bad you
know what my big point is is just the
chill the [ __ ] out
look you ever be respectful without
having to try so hard it's like the
classic situation with that one white
dude in the neighborhood that tries to
act super hood every time you see the
black guy I remember in high school
there was always that one kid that did
that [ __ ] it was weird
he would always talk like himself but
the moment one black male of mine he
just went full-on stupid hey Steve did
you finish the homework yesterday oh
[ __ ] I forgot you don't poop yeah but I
was like [ __ ] it your favorite Duke
ran up on me I was like did it work
Oh what is going on YouTube thank you
guys in two minute watching the videos
cuz you already know that I upload on
Sundays or Mondays so make sure you guys
always check in then now everybody you
guys want to copy or you can always go
to go for broke apparel dot-com you got
some fresh [ __ ] and yes because the
spring line just started up a couple of
the new designs are on sale laughs and
if you guys are wondering my funny FATF
it has not been uploaded recently it's
gonna go back up but I once again I'm
just waiting for my back to kill lot and
it's almost there but I can actually
start doing workouts again so just stay
in tune for that just funny fast babe
always keep it going and always keep you
strong I am coming back funny fact it
will be revving back up again just
remember don't give up just because I
did not do my videos this is your goal
this is your life
keep it up I believe you had a quick
special announcement if you guys already
don't know I used to do music seconds a
day I was actually pretty serious about
it so I'm actually gonna be putting out
a few new songs recently couple covers
and an original [ __ ] for your listening
pleasure so stay tuned for that
alright we'll see y'all soon shipping
about baby boom baby ma stop bein that
is English
[Music]
see what was too crazy never thought
she'd never come at me that way
I kept it real with our feet for you so
she knew that I was